IT IS TIME TO PLAY SURVIVAL
OF THE DICKISH.
SURVIVAL OF THE DICKISH.
NOW IF YOU LIKE TO WATCH A
LOT OF NATURE SPECIALS IN
YOUR UNDERWEAR LIKE I DO,
YOU WOULD KNOW THAT ANIMAL
KINGDOM IT IS A FIERCE
COMPETITION TO STAY ALIVE SO,
NATURALLY SOME CREATURES ARE
AS SELFISH AS BRIDEZILLAS.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A GIF
FROM THE ANIMALS BEING
DICKS TUMBLR, YOU HAVE TO GIVE
YOUR BEST NATURE DOCUMENTARY
STYLE COMMENTARY, ALL RIGHT?
FIRST UP, DON'T INVITE A
PENGUIT TO YOUR WEDDING BECAUSE
HE'S WEARING A TUXEDO.
>> IS THAT PEE OR POOP?
>> I THINK IT'S PEE?
>> YEAH, I DO, TOO.
>> Chris: JO.
>> SCORCH THE PENG WISH LETS
THE OTHER PENGUIN KNOW THAT
THIS IS HIS BITCH.
>> Chris: POINTS.
PERSONALLY, I THINK THE PENGUIN
IS LIKE, BITCH YOU SHOULDN'T BE
WEARING WHITE, YOU GUYS
TOTALLY [BLEEP] --
>> I ALSO KNOW WHY HE PEED.
BECAUSE HE IS A PENGUIN
IN A [BLEEP] KITCHEN AND HE
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON.
>> YEAH.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE.
TAKE A GANDER AT THIS
HORNY HUSKEY.
OKAY.
WELL.
>> IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE DOG
IS LIKE SPECIAL DELIVERY?
FOR ME?
(LAUGHTER)
>> SCORE!
>> Chris: JEN.
>> IN SOME REMOTE PARTS OF
THE WORLD, THE SPECIES KNOWN
AS FAMILY DOG IF THERE IS A
FATHER ABSENT WILL HAVE TO
SHOW A CHILD THE FACTS OF LIFE.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: POINTS FOR JEN
KIRKMAN.
MATT.
>> THE DOG IS TEACHING THE
CHILD A VALUABLE LESSON
WHICH IS RUNNING OFF AND
GOING YEAH, YOU THOUGHT
WOULD YOU HAVE FUN ON THE
SLED, HUH, THEN YOU FELL
OFF.
THAT IS WHAT YOU GET.
LIFE [BLEEP] YOU IN THE ASS,
KID!
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE?
THIS DOG IS NOT HAVING A
GOOD BIRTHDAY.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY --
AH.
(LAUGHTER)
I DON'T WANT IT.
I DON'T [BLEEP] WANT IT!
I SAID I DON'T WANT IT!
>> KIRKMAN.
>> DO YOU KNOW ME AT ALL?
I TOLD YOU SUGAR AND
GLUTEN-FREE!